you guys know we work our way through
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
here on the live stream of the [ __ ] list
roundup we go through the [ __ ] list
uh there's a lot of things on the [ __ ]
list but the main thing
the main thing
is the main fear that we have in this
country is big bird oh big bird that
[ __ ] commie bastard so let's get
right to it and start the countdown
[Music]
welcome back to the [ __ ] list roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trending trends of today on the
[ __ ] list the [ __ ] list
as you guys know we have a podcast every
wednesday four o'clock eastern three
o'clock central and we run through the
[ __ ] list roundup on the show so we
round up all the [ __ ] list and then we
do it on the show
so join us on the podcast
so go check that out it's live
wednesdays three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern on youtube twitter
twitch uh same same place as the stream
here but you wanna go uh subscribe to
youtube or or download the twitch app
and follow us on twitch that's a good
place to watch the podcast too and a
good place to watch the streams cause
what you can do
is you can actually uh watch the stream
while you're surfing twitter or doing
whatever i mean josh hollywood be
watching porn and playing video games
but whatever you want to do while you're
watching the [ __ ] list roundup you can
do that on your cell phone or anywhere
else if you're using the twitch app
so you might go download the twitch app
i guess again if you're manly enough if
you're manly enough
josh holly
have you seen this [ __ ]
so um the two biggest fears apparently
well the three biggest fears
but uh josh holly wrapped two two of the
fears up in one
is
that that men are watching too much porn
and playing too much video games and
that makes them not manly
i mean is he like projecting here i
can't figure this out if this guy is
just pissed off that he's not good at
call of duty and he doesn't know how to
search porn worth the [ __ ] and he's like
on porn like six hours a day or
something trying to find what he what he
can jerk off to and i don't know what
the [ __ ] he's doing or what the [ __ ]
he's talking about
really honestly
in in today's age what's more [ __ ]
mainly than jerking off and playing call
of duty i mean isn't that what their
entire [ __ ] base is
isn't that what they do isn't that the
[ __ ] that they to talk about that's
what's manly
you know all these [ __ ]
insurrectionists that think they're
big and bad i'm just saying
let's look at some big bird content
because that's the other thing they're
really [ __ ] scared of they're [ __ ]
terrified
[ __ ] terrified a big bird oh my god
big bird a fictional character said he
got vaccinated big bird can't get
vaccinated he's [ __ ] fake it's not
real why
why the [ __ ] is it that the right wing
believes all these fictional things
like of course they believe big bird
actually got vaccinated they [ __ ]
what they thought jfk jr was gonna come
back from the dead and run with trump or
i don't know
fly into the white house on a [ __ ]
carpet or something i can't figure this
[ __ ] [ __ ] out
but they think big bird actually got
vaccinated this is a fictional character
that has a twitter account and he
tweeted out let's
let's go see if we can find this [ __ ]
thing
because really
really the the problem here is that
they're canceling big bird and they're
rooting for the virus we need to stop
the cult
let's see let's search for
let's search for needy boom boom boom
boom let's uh
that's not what i want let's search for
big bird here big bird let's find big
birds account and let's let's look at
the tweet from big bird that they're
[ __ ] freaking out about
okay here it is
oh i need to uh i need to give big bird
credit here
give me just one second i gotta get that
get that get the credit credits here
going um
there we go okay
okay
all right now we can get big bird credit
for reading his tweet um and dude let's
just go ahead and just put it in there
boom
oh look president biden even uh
[Laughter]
trolling [ __ ]
and
good on
we'll read that one too and give credit
here but let's go to big bird big bird
says i got the coven 19 vaccine today my
wing is feeling a little sore but i'll
give my but it'll give my body an extra
protective boost that keeps me and
others healthy
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it this is not different than any other
sesame street message
this is not any different this is not
[ __ ] propaganda you dumb [ __ ] this
is simply big bird giving a psa to
children that hey
if you get the vaccine don't worry it's
not gonna be uh it's not gonna be with
all the crazy ass [ __ ] queuing owners
that are standing in front of the
walmart with the signs that are trying
to scare your mommy and your daddy into
you not getting the vaccine it's not
it's not gonna hurt it really is it
really is safe all that other q anon
stuff is just [ __ ]
because i'm i'm gonna show a uh
a psa that big bird did
back in 1972 apparently he's been uh a
commie deep stater for 40 years 40
almost 50 years [ __ ]
who would have thought that big bird
would have been able to hide in the
commie deep state for 50 [ __ ] years
he has that son of a [ __ ]
but here
again
this is just of this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
where they remember when they i'm old
enough to remember
when they were bitching uh that mr
potato head was cancelled and dr seuss
and and
just on and on and on with it
they were mad that the mlb moved the
[ __ ] game because
they were trying to pass laws where you
couldn't hand out [ __ ] snacks in a
goddamn a water you couldn't hand out
water in a voting line in georgia
and the mlb is like that's the dumbest
[ __ ] anti-democracy thing we've ever
[ __ ] heard of and you if you do it we
won't [ __ ] have the all-star game
here and they moved it to colorado
they moved it to colorado because they
were just [ __ ] sick and tired of the
[ __ ]
with these [ __ ] gq peers
and and then they rambled on and on and
on about how mr potato head was getting
cancelled and that mr potato head was
never canceled go into a [ __ ] walmart
you [ __ ] toothless fools
and see that mr potato head is sitting
on the shelf and on the box it says mr
potato head
these [ __ ] boneheads but they're now
they're gonna cancel big bird because
he's a commie because he's promoting you
know things like making sure you
and others are healthy that's what
scissors keeps me and others healthy you
read it
keeps me and others healthy [ __ ]
boneheads
oh [ __ ] well and then again it continues
to talk about uh getting vaccines since
he was a little bird i had no idea says
miss erica hill
even said i've been getting vaccines
since i was a little bird i had no idea
and maybe that's where they're pissed
off because they're poking fun at
they're poking fun at historical
vaccine data this isn't
they want to act like this is the first
[ __ ] vaccine that's ever [ __ ]
ever of the history of ever ever it's
the only vaccine that's ever been given
to you people are [ __ ] dumb
these fact we have we have historical
data on vaccines
and there has never
never in the history of vaccines has
there been one that [ __ ] kills mass
amounts of people or makes people
have a certain condition or some [ __ ]
dumb ass [ __ ] that they're making up
some stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
that causes them to go to dr joe rogan
to get their ivermectin advice
jesus [ __ ] christ
they they're they're really happy about
aaron rodgers and they're pissed off at
big bird aaron rodgers an actual person
who's doing dumb [ __ ] things big bird
is a fictional character
who is pretending it's pretending to do
the right thing which maybe if we had
more [ __ ] people in this country
not pretending just actually doing the
right thing like aaron rodgers should
have done which was get the vaccine or
and not [ __ ] lie about it
jesus [ __ ]
it just it it it is incredible
how this is uh playing out here but
let's let's uh do let's go back and
let's read uh the president's response
let's see what is he
good on you big bird getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep your whole
neighborhood safe
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
these [ __ ] twits man
jesus christ
of course uh i think it was ted cruz
that weighed in on this stupid thing um
more than and that was kind of what it
was
and and ted cruz is actually trending
when we get to the trendy trends and the
tweety tweets here
uh we'll go over that
but i want to show you a couple videos
of big bird here why we're on the
subject while we're on the subject um
this um
muppet
wiki i believe is the uh yeah muppet
wiki is the let's go to their account
and let's give them credit uh to the
original post here
so we can see it
because i thought it was really good um
they actually posted big bird fighting
forces of evil since 1980 so i'm
guessing this clip is from 1980 uh by
muppet wiki um and uh it's big bird
promoting um fighting fashion i mean
evil
fascism evil trumpism you know fascism
in the manga head let's listen to what
uh big bird says about fighting
super bird
shazam pow zach super bird here fighting
the forces of evil anyone in distress
fighting the forces of evil
i love it
i love it i love it i love it thank you
muppet wiki and i i actually reposted
the video and i said what did i say i
said big bird fights fascism
big bird fights fascism
and someone else
wrote a really good quote tweet here
um
t-dog writes
it's a bird no really it's it's a bird
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good one i like it
well uh we'll put the j and give credit
since we read it all right thank you
credit since we read it and credit since
we read it and credited since we read it
okay let's see
did he do oh trump university's trending
as well
let's go let's go to another um while
we're talking about big bird here
dude i think it's somewhere around here
no [ __ ] i didn't post it so i'm gonna
have to go um
yeah that's i'm gonna want and so we
want to go there okay
we'll find this video here
um and i actually think this was posted
by um
[Music]
this one um
polly tweet
good picture here you see uh who is that
green bay packer laying on the ground oh
they're arresting bidburg what the [ __ ]
breaking big bird is taking into custody
after beating the living [ __ ] out of
aaron rodgers for spreading
misinformation about ivermectin and
kovid vaccinations
[Laughter]
that's hilarious okay there you go
credit thank you for the tweet paulie
okay
[Music]
okay
what's a bad dog have to say here
mad dog says i'm gonna need a grown a
grown up to sit little ted cruz down and
explain to him about big birds and the
bees
big birds and the bees
do thank you for your tweet mad dog okay
what else we got what else we got
let's see jesus [ __ ] christ says so
big bird is smarter than aaron rodgers
yes
yes the fictional character big bird
is smarter than aaron rodgers
has more [ __ ] sense and more [ __ ]
respect for his goddamn neighbors
[Music]
i'm looking for this video that uh
i think it was from 1972. maybe we
should go back to uh muppet wiki maybe
that's where where it will live
because it's um
it shows a psa that they did
[Music]
here's one from sesame street themselves
and they say
when was this posted
so it looks like this is this morning
big bird may have just received his
coved back scene covet 19 vaccine but as
many of you pointed out he was he
learning how to keep himself and his
neighbors healthy long before that
this is from 1972 so here is uh
here's a two-minute clip let's watch
this
[Music]
oh hi
hey i didn't see you
for it
boy i'm glad you came because it's such
a nice day i thought i'd walk down to
the store you know see what's cooking
something's going on down at this door
he sees something
what is it big bird funny i mean it's
strange i mean
well there's all kinds of people and
they're all in a line and they don't
look like they're buying candy and
there's a sign that says
don't wait
vaccinate so
this is a
1972. now if you're aware
there was a video and i posted it too of
the annie griffith show um doing a show
about getting a shot they talked about
getting shots uh they didn't call it a
vaccine on the andy griffith show they
just called it getting a shot
back then there were several vaccines
that they were trying to get people to
get um one of them was typhoid typhoid
in the 50s 60s and 70s early 70s
they were trying to get a vaccine out to
people and make them aware that it was
one way to avoid typhoid
like there was a very effective vaccine
that was
proven the data and then they developed
it
sometime during the second world war but
the the out was slow in this country hmm
familiar
but uh
but they were trying to promote so they
were using shows like the andy griffith
show and even uh sesame street here
obviously to get out the message that
hey
we have these vaccines that are
effective against disease
you should get them
it's a good way to prevent
um getting disease so
so
because they had typhoid they had
measles um there was all sorts of
vaccines that they had that they were
trying to get people to be aware of
and
there goes a boy with a balloon coming
out of the store hey what's going on
here hey tom
hi big bird how are you doing great
what's going on here oh well today's the
day when the the the city vaccination
units come come to the neighborhood and
uh they set up a measles vaccination
clinic here in the store
you mean something like a hospital right
here in mr luper's store yeah well sort
of uh you know they've got all their
equipment and heels and things and
the kids are going to go in and get
vaccinated so they won't catch the
measles gosh well uh if you're a
hospital
then uh
uh you must have a nurse sure you've got
a nurse you do yeah
now
you know i'm a trained nurse
so you see here a sesame street let me
uh give credit here since i showed it
not that sesame street gives a [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] list roundup but you know
they might
um
but here obviously we have
big bird
uh he's he's uh
he's promoting the vaccine and he's
being a commie deep stater obviously now
again these right wingers don't have a
problem or didn't have a problem with
big bird
uh and the vaccine
even though this little clip exists like
again this is all [ __ ] fake outrage
that they are trying to run on they're
trying to promote they're trying to say
oh it's cancer culture the woke mob
all this [ __ ] fake ass [ __ ]
because that's all it is it's fake ass
[ __ ] so there's the uh
there's the clip from 1972
to give you proof that uh big bird was a
commie
since 1972
okay
let's see
[Laughter]
hudlum says the real reason the gqp he
says gop but gqp is mad at big bird
oh
could that be the reason i think it
might be it could be
uh we're gonna give credit for reading
it thanks a lot hoovland i appreciate it
well
not hood them hood them right okay
see see here's the [ __ ] stupid-ass
[ __ ] here's the stupid-ass [ __ ] this is
the stupid [ __ ] wendy rogers this
[ __ ] q and on freak out in arizona
just a [ __ ] complete bonehead
big bird is a communist
look
people have been taking vaccinations in
this [ __ ] country
for hundreds of years we've been getting
inoculated and having inoculation
mandates
vaccine mandates
for a long [ __ ] time we've had
vaccine mandates and we've had vaccines
and they [ __ ] work it's this isn't
the first [ __ ] one you [ __ ]
boneheads
i'm going to give credit here but you
know
i'm not going to thank her
your tweet
sucks
hope if i could [ __ ] spell
your tweet
sucks
it's a [ __ ] horrible tweet
[ __ ] idiot
i'm wendy rogers what a [ __ ] bonehead
nip
big bird's a communist well you know
what you know what
you better be careful calling fictional
characters like big bird who children
look up to
communist
if you guys really imprint on the on
this young generation who look up to big
bird who know that big bird isn't a
communist and you say he's a communist
they might just grow up thinking hey
well
big bird's a communist i mean
big birds are coming in and so what the
hell's the big deal
let's see if there's any other good big
bird tweets here
i want i want some more big bird content
i'm here for the big bird content this
morning
is there any other good big bird content
uh you know they're gonna be running
with this uh big bird [ __ ] for
[ __ ] weeks i mean weeks they're gonna
be talking about big bird how and and
i'm sure i'm sure by the end of the day
today and sometime this week it'll be on
tucker carlson that big bird supports
critical race theory i'm not [ __ ]
you they're going to intertwine the this
[ __ ] fake outrage they always
intertwine the fake outrage
because there's fake [ __ ] outrage
over critical race theory because
they're [ __ ] spreading lies about it
and and uh
it's the voodoo the voodoo critical race
theory but again they're gonna
intertwine these stupid [ __ ] things
and somehow big bird's gonna support
critical race theory i'm almost certain
of it that he's some kind of critical
race theory commie antifa which i mean
honestly what better could you have then
i guess like okay so big bird for
president i guess i don't know if he
[ __ ] if if he [ __ ] pisses you you
stupid idiots off so much then yeah
maybe big bird should run for senate
senate of sesame street
we are again we are at the intersection
of wrestlemania in real life but maybe
we are also at the intersection of
wrestlemania and sesame street
and on one corner there's the dr joe
rogan ivermectin institute
and the other corner is the the [ __ ]
mr potato head big bird costume shop
um trump university is in the news
and because uh austin the university of
austin or some dumb [ __ ] just trying to
open up the
trump university 2.0
i said have you
heard someone brag about their degree
from trump university i've never met
anyone i've never heard anyone on tape
i've never actually heard like someone
brag about their degree
from trump university i wonder if anyone
will brag about their degree
from the university of trumpism i mean
austin whatever